excusez moi c'était une question de 2 ap
est bien d'abord mesdames et messieurs
merci merci d'être ici aussi nombreux
merci à vous tous ici présents je dois
avouer que je n'ai pas l'habitude de ce
genre d'exercice mais et c'est assez
impressionnant mais bon on y est on y va
merci aux orateurs parce que s'il ya un
bel échange qui se passe ici dans cette
salle je vous assure depuis quelques
heures
on se connaissait pas mais absolument
pas du tout mais il ya aussi eu beaucoup
de chance et beaucoup de similitudes
beaucoup de connexions
merci à eux c'est vraiment un grand
bonheur de partager toute cette
expérience
merci évidemment aussi à toute équipe du
tedx pour cette magnifique organisation
alors je vais vous parler des arbres je
dois vous avouer que je suis mais je
suis un passionné
d'ailleurs vous avez il faudra m'arrêter
vous allez le voir on va on va un petit
peu voyagé aussi puisqu'on a
on a vous avouer que j'ai les yeux et
les yeux pleins d'étoilés
j'ai les oreilles la musique j'ai mon
coeur plein d'émotions points 2 de
belles sensations et c'est un petit peu
ce que je retrouve dans tous les arbres
et pourquoi pourquoi est ce qu'on est
on est tout un chacun a tiré par ces
arbres lagarde c'est la vie ces cadres
vivent le plus grand le plus vieux et
plus large du monde de toute notre
histoire on a il était bien avant nous
sera terre 380 millions d'années et plus
et tentez plus on emmenait je pense à
200 migrants pour un homme aux dernières
mesures je sais par femme c'est ce que
j'ai vu dans les chiffres
alors quelques exemples de grands arbres
il semblerait que ce soit le plus grand
quoique non mais voici un séquoia géant
la petite flèche que vous voyez là en
rouge ça présentant un homme que dire
quand on est devant un tel arbre même
chose ici ça se passe évidemment
californie dans ce parc national de doré
doute avec aussi cet arbre tout aussi
impressionnant qui petite histoire 28 m
de circonférence c'est quand même
quelque chose et là j'estime et 3200 en
mai c'était pas plus grands champions
enfin c'est pas dans les séquoias il y
en a un plus haut c'est celui ci c'est
hyper ion qui est aussi en californie
même on a on sait pas très bien où il
est en tout cas sa présence et à les
protéger
on ne veut pas on ne veut pas parce
qu'il ya des mains démago truc je veux
dire les gens peu respectueux de la
nature qui en profiterait d'ailleurs on
va le voir plus tard un autre exemple de
grands arbres 7 au mexique avec le
cyprès ici de monter humains 42 m de
circonférence on a longtemps cru que
c'était c'était un ensemble de plusieurs
arts mais non ce n'est qu'un arbre un
seul l'unique arbre est encore plus
grand mais leur grandeur c'est un petit
peu aussi leur malheur ce sont les deux
qualités de tasmanie 130 mètres de haut
vous imaginez mais ils font l'objet
d'une exploitation intensive
tout ça pour un bis l'industrie le
papier tout ça part en chine
ici juste au pied de voyez ici de souche
avec qui se tient
juste dessus vous imaginez ce que ça
peut donner
il ya quand même des gens qui qui ont eu
vent de ça et qui sont un petit peu un
petit peu respectueux et qui disent on
va essayer d'en sauver et contre vents
et marées ils ont sauvé ils ont sauvé 74
mille hectares c'est pas grand chose
mais c'est déjà ça
mais qu'est ce qui pousse les hommes à
admirer autant désarmé aussi à les
exploiter parce que de tous temps quand
on voit ces images on les a on les a
exploitées pourtant les mi moyens
mécaniques n'y était pas mais on l'a
fait c'était quoi c'était le défi le
défi de faire mieux d'aller plus haut
dans les plus grands je ne sais pas
toujours éthiques
un autre drame et qui est tout à fait
aussi tout à six présences et en
birmanie il faut savoir qu'il ya plus de
tech en birmanie issus de générations de
germination naturel
c'était une forêt primaire sur moins de
50 ans en 2010 il y avait encore 47%
attend 2015 si on n'a plus tout ça pour
profits il faut savoir qu'à la birmanie
et a dirigé par une junte militaire et
ils font ils font profil de tout bois
alors on va quand même aller plus loin
on va voir qu'il n'ya pas que de
mauvaises choses
le plus vieux arbres on vous parlait
tout à l'heure de 3200 celui-ci 4847 ans
et je vous assure qui est bien vivant
contrairement à l'homme car voilà ces
deux facultés de d'avoir en lui des
cellules mortes et aussi de développer
des jeunes ces grumes et qui permettent
de vivre et cette arme est bien vivant
et un jeune con excusez moi d'exprimer
des expressions qui pour des études
scientifiques par été abattu son cousin
qui était situé à quelques centaines de
mètres de lui
c'est bien dommage un autre un autre
exemple d'arbres remarquables d'un bon
vieux en if un taxi au pays de galles
quatre migrants
c'est quand même pas mal
et ici en france me direz-vous ben voilà
on a ici exemple d'un vivier à
roquebrune qui lui aurait deux mig en
lorraine on les laisse aller de migrants
l'arbre au delà de toutes ces
considérations morphologique de toutes
ces tailles de toutes ces chiffres et
ces dégâts représente énormément de
choses pour tout un chacun c'est d'abord
une notion plaisir qui n'a pas souvenir
pendant ses vacances cet été de cette
radio s'est ain harrouda avoir fait une
petite sieste d'avoir fait peut-être un
petit dodo un petit câlin ou en tout cas
avoir pris beaucoup de plaisir
c'est une notion très importante les
arbres aussi au niveau de l'éducation
on s'est aperçu que il y avait un impact
assez important et surtout on parlait de
pédagogie tout à l'heure mais les
enfants sont très réceptifs à cette
approche de la nature et surtout à cette
je vais dire cette connexion et je dois
avouer que peu d'expérience enfin on a
eu quelques expériences avec eux et
c'est réellement très positif non
seulement ce jour là mais ce sont
vraiment nos futurs ambassadeurs et ce
sont les protecteurs de d'une vie d'une
vie meilleure en tout cas pour nos
arbres même chose pour au niveau social
les personnes à mobilité réduite des
personnes qu'on doit réinsérer personnes
à problèmes eh bien il semble que la
proche de l'arbre était très bénéfique
pour eux en fait on a aussi le côté
historique de cet arbre de liberté un
art qui est planté en souvenir d'un acte
héroïque d'une décision d'un
installations de bâtiments d'une
naissance parce que ça se fait de plus
en plus un enfant qui nait ont porté un
ardent jardin c'est peut-être pas une
mauvaise idée
c'est même une excellente idée verte
climatique évidemment on sait il
rafraîchit l'air herbe antipollution
voilà on sait que bientôt sa synthèse
bien c
c'est un des rôles essentiels gandon qui
capte les gaz carboniques et rejette
d'oxygène tout ça par un phénomène
chimique et inconnue de la plupart
alors cette photo jean gaury n'est pas
anodine ce ginkgo biloba arbre aux
quarante écus qui est un résineux qui a
des feuilles qui perd des feuilles c'est
un résineux il fait partie de la
quinzaine au sperme ça se protège
histoire mais pour la grande histoire
aussi cet arbre a survécu en tout cas
repoussée après les bombardements
d'hiroshima
après attaque atomique après le
bombardement atomique qui a repoussé
donc c'est dire combien ces arbres sont
résistants la banque érosion ben oui ça
je n'invente rien non plus j'ai des
racines etc
on utilise dans dans la préservation des
berges chevron des cours d'eau antibruit
aussi que ce soit en en gommant
dirigeants milieu urbain au monde et
autoroutes etc entier bruissement bon ça
tout un chacun il ya des gens qui aiment
dieu soleil d'autres pas
c'est aussi un élément architectural qui
permet de structurer paysages que ce
soit angers que ce soit devant des
routes a gardé un carrefour dans d'un
point d'un rond-point d'un point
essentiel
il structure paysage est très important
il peut aussi cacher aussi certaine
morosité
ici on est en passant de charleroi qui
n'est pas la plus belgique de belgique
bien que vit bien mais voilà ces arbres
ont été plantés pour donner un petit peu
de gaieté à ce quartier c'est pas gagné
vous me direz si parce que quand ils
sont en fait oui évidemment il participa
aux paysages de au caractère paysage de
nos villes est un aspect aussi qui est
souvent négligée mais qui est important
ils sont bourrés je pense qu'ici il ya
quand même quelques et que personne tant
mobile dans l'immobilier pardon en biens
qui augmenterait la plus-value fait
d'avoir un arbre ses conséquences sur
son terrain de ces drames il y aurait
une plus value de 2 15%
mais c'est aussi
quelque part un être vivant qui nous
fait peur parce que parce que il ya
plein de gens aussi qui sont qui sont
inféodés à garbrah des gens ont plein de
points de primes s'ouvrir lui en lui
donne aussi un souvenez vous cette
blanche neige qui court à tout apeuré au
milieu de la forêt et qui est agrippée
par les arbres oui pourquoi certains
disent certains auteurs disent ben oui
ils croient illzach on voit pas très
bien comment elle grandit on voit pas
très bien comment on entend pas on
n'entend pas vivre et pourtant il est
bien là et je vous assure que si vous
écoutez y plein de choses à dire alors
on doit tous ses aspects ces arbres et
ce sont des êtres vivants mais fragile
et bien souvent et pourtant ces gars on
a besoin de ça c'est vraiment là leur
place ils jouent un rôle essentiel dans
milieu urbain eh bien ils sont pas
ménagés en milieu urbain voici ici
quelques exemples
voilà encore d'autres sur ces cinq
photos il ya trois arts qui ont été
abattus on comprend pourquoi évidemment
mais ils se ils se battent se battent
ces arbres il ne baisse pas les bras
comme ça ils sont ils ont des
possibilités énorme énorme
voici un exemple un exemple de
comparaison entre un art qui croient en
milieu forestier est un art qui croient
en milieu urbain et on appris ici j'ai
pris un exemple de mon ami françois
freytet et qui me dit voilà ce qu'est ce
qu'ils considèrent au niveau d'eau en
milieu urbain bien évidemment on a en a
je vais dire un seul compact et qui ne
permet pas ou très peu en tout cas
d'infiltration d'eau mais développement
des racines et racinaire est limité et
difficile et pillards aux âges est
occasionnelle et qui puisait on ne voit
pas ici mais
les faits sont assez systématiquement en
ville et donc il ya peu d'apport de
matières organiques alors comment il
s'organise noar pour pour vivre en ville
parce que ça c'est un aspect je veux
dire je dirais que c'est l'aspect
plantations à côté de ça il ya un autre
aspect est que j'étais aujourd'hui parce
que 18 minutes pour parer désarmons pas
emparée des journées entières
il ya l'aspect aussi taillé josé vous et
que chapeau à la veille de valenciennes
parce que les arguments d'arbres et
s'ils sont taillés de manière on ne peut
plus correct de manière vraiment vous
avez deux bouts aux aliments d'air vous
avez une gestion des arbres en v qui est
qui est très bien qui est très simple
c'est pas le cas partout et je vous
avouer que je suis à chaque fois charmé
d'abord dans le choix des essences et
puis dans le choix du soin qui est
apporté aux tailles vous êtes vraiment
bien bien bien entouré bien encadré la
preuve en est aussi ici sur le parking
les jeunes plantations qui ont été
faites c'est du matériel de qualité ça a
été fait avec beaucoup de avec beaucoup
de professionnalisme alors je dirai
comment comment il évoque comment ils
s'adaptent à bien il ya un phénomène qui
s'appelle la minorisation cette
mutualisation c'est un pacte c'est une
association entre entre les symbiose
entre entre entre des racines et des
champignons qui sont dans le sommes
naturellement et et racines des arbres
produits de glucides qui va développer
ses mycorhizes semih curistes qui vont
favoriser l'assimilation des sels
minéraux et et de vaud et donc ça va
favoriser la croissance
ça marche tellement bien que je viens de
sauver anti eu de 300 ans
on a enlevé carrément 40 cm de terre on
a remis un nouveau substrat on a injecté
des mycorhizes puisqu'on le fait
maintenant est possible la technique la
technologie nous nous permet quand même
beaucoup de choses et c'est tarbes est
reparti pour au moins 300 ans
je suis très heureux
alors une autre adaptation aussi ces
gars-là stamos anastomose qu'est ce que
c'est vraiment une soudure de racine
c'était particulier ils peuvent non
seulement sous des racines en un art peu
soudée sa racine ses propres racines
entre elles mais il peut aussi sous des
racines ses racines à sec du voisin et
donc ça nous donne aussi des choses un
peu particulière comme en inde
on a carrément des ponts dépens de
racines comme ça qui se sont soudés les
unes aux autres et qui se sont accrochés
c'en est fait quand même pervers ce nom
ça peut être ça c'est bénéfique au
niveau sorti un stress hydrique par
exemple on s'est aperçu que le voisin
pouvait réguler et des peut-être par
exemple un art qui est près d'un
ruisseau
eh bien il alimenter en eau son voisin
mais c'est un effet pervers aussi c'est
pour la propagation de certaines
maladies d'agents pathogènes
la preuve en est avec nos platanes du
sud qui ont qui ont malheureusement dû
être abattu alors quand on voit toutes
ces forêts que ce soit ici en france que
ce soit en europe que ce soit en
amazonie que ce soit un peu partout dans
le monde
ces forêts mélangé de résineux et de
feuillus
on voit ici la dense forêt tropicale
c'est tout à fait une flore tout à fait
extraordinaire où se mélangent déjà des
petits des grands des vieux des gros des
gens qui qui n'ont rien à faire ensemble
mais il arrive à vivre ensemble et non
seulement il arrive enfin
ensemble ils arrivent à se protéger à se
protéger parce qu'on a pas pareil vous
ai pas parlé de 2,2 faune on à paris
qu'un peu de choix mais l'entomofaune
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
certains arbres ont par exemple la
faculté d'accueillir des insectes qui
sont des prédateurs d'autres insectes
sur d'autres arbres et ainsi de suite
alors quand on voit ça moi je dis et
c'est une très très belle leçon et qu'on
pourrait vraiment suivre par exemple je
vous remercie de votre attention